MANDY WAITE: Could you provide
us with state-of-the-art
database model designs?
Oh, OK.
That's a big ask.
Things like CRM database model,
a Bookshelf, an eBay
kind of application.
FRED SAUER: OK.
It sounds to me like the person
asking the question is
kind of looking for sample
model, sample applications.
And I hear kind of the question
behind the question,
which is, how do I go about
modeling an e-commerce site, a
CRM site, in this
non-relational, NoSQL world?
I want to build an application
that can handle tremendous
scale, but you've kind of
swapped the tools out for me.
I'm used to doing development on
a SQL database, relational.
I know how that works, but I
know that that doesn't scale.
So help me switch.
I think it's difficult to come
up with samples that fit every
single vertical, but there are
some general things that we
can say about the way you
do data modeling.
And really, it's sort of
changing some of your habits
and some of the things that you
were taught, maybe from
the beginning, working with
relational databases.
So one of the first tenets
when you're building a
relational database model is
everything needs to be
normalized, no data
duplicated.
It's typical in an order entry
system to have 5, 6, 7, 10, 12
different tables, that every
time you want to do a query
and find out what the orders
are, you have to join all
these tables at run time and
select your results.
So you might have a table that
has items in it, and it has
item description, item price,
and some other information.
Then you have an order
lines, which
connects to an order header.
You have order line details.
It goes on and on.
And this is a really good way of
allowing you, at run time,
the flexibility to really join
any amount of data with any
other amount of data, which
is what relational
databases were built for.
But in a very scalable world,
what you want is actually that
if you and I both make a request
to our website and
we're both interacting with the
service, what we want is
for your queries and my queries
to essentially be able
to be handled by different parts
of the infrastructure.
So it's a distributed platform,
and the way to do
that is to sort of isolate
your data from my data.
And that means what we don't
want is, if I'm pulling up a
list of my orders and you're
pulling up a list of your
orders, we don't want to both be
going to the same table and
kind of running into
each other.
We also don't want to take a lot
of time at run time kind
of collecting the data.
In a distributed system, what
you like to do is kind of
amortize the cost, spread out
the costs, and do the cost at
write time.
So when we write the data, we
might do some deduplication,
so what you would call
denormalization.
So it's quite common in App
Engine apps for entities to
have properties with
string values.
So rather than have an item key
on your item details page,
you would actually have, like,
the actual item code or the
actual description.
If you're putting together,
let's say, countries, you have
a kind that stores addresses
and you need countries.
In App Engine, you would
actually just put the country
code or even the full country
name in every single entity.
And you should kind of resist
that urge to say, oh, I don't
want the duplication of data.
I don't want to pay for
the extra storage.
What you're really doing is
you're separating your data
and my data and making it very
efficient to handle a very
large number of requests.
There's more best practices,
but the first one that you
kind of want to think about
is denormalization
is not a bad thing.
It's actually something you
should really just embrace.
Just pick two users and imagine
that they're both
doing kind of the same thing
in your application.
How can you make it so that
the entities that you're
touching and the entities that
I'm touching are different?
Because as soon as they're
separated from each other,
then the Google App Engine
infrastructure, the datastore,
can put those entities on
different physical hardware,
different machines, and now we
can add a third user, a fourth
user, a fifth user.
We can have 100,000 users.
It really doesn't matter how big
we scale up because each
user's accessing a different
part of the system.
So it's kind of a lot to grasp
if you're coming from a SQL
environment.
But once you play around with
it for a little while, it's
really framed to say, I really
don't care how many users show
up on my doorstep tomorrow.
I can handle 1,000
users, a million
users, a billion users.
It's really independent
of the scale.
And that's what the App Engine
datastore provides is
performance that's independent
of the amount
of data that's stored.
MANDY WAITE: Excellent.
That's really good advice.
FRED SAUER: All right.
So, sorry for the long
answer there.
MANDY WAITE: No, I think it's
the kind of question that
deserves a long answer.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
It's a common question,
so it's fair to spend
a little more time.
MANDY WAITE: A lot of people
moving from the traditional,
relational database over to
the NoSQL type of work.
FRED SAUER: Oh.
And we should say if you do
want a relational system--
you have a limited number of
users, you're building a
corporate application, you
only know you'll need the
existing performance-- you
can use Google Cloud SQL.
It's a MySQL database,
runs in the cloud,
managed for you, no headaches.
And you can get all the
traditional kind of
performance trade-offs
and benefits.
So that's still an option.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.